je voulais une autre façon de partager
ce lourd fardeau que vous avez vécu et
quand le terrain ne devrait jamais avoir
un livre 48 ans plus tard la famille de
Sharon prayer enfin les réponses qu'elle
attendait aujourd'hui nous pouvons
confirmer avec les résultats d'expertise
biologique obtenu que Franklin est à 100
% responsable de la mort de Sharon fire
un soulagement pour ses sœurs jumelles
que sharing n'aura connu qu'un bref
moment ce soir
[Musique]
rejoindre des amis dans une pizzeria de
Pointe Saint-Charles elle ne sait jamais
rendu trois jours plus tard son corps
violentés a été retrouvé sur un terrain
vague à Longueuil le rapport de Topsy
avait conclu que l'adolescente avait été
violée puis battue à mort
des années plus tard grâce à la
généalogie génétique des échantillons
d'ADN prélevés sur les vêtements de la
jeune victime et du présumé agresseur
ont permis de déterminer le profil du
suspect numéro 1 dans cette affaire
Franklin romain le bus c'est dans les
prochaines années d'en avoir d'enfermer
deux peut-être trois par année une
première pour les enquêteurs de
Longueuil qui espèrent accélérer la
cadence dans le dénouement de crimes non
résolus
pour que les familles des victimes elles
puissent enfin tourner la page ici
Gabriel prout Radio-Canada Montréal